[Music]
a farewell to another live car short the
mounting tool of this conflict now in
his third week
21 year old alexander velishko was
killed on the first day of the war
he was on the front line in the lugans
region in the east of the country
it took two weeks for his body to be
retrieved and brought back to his
hometown
i was in touch with him the day before
this happened his spirits were high it's
difficult to describe the loss hard to
express the army didn't change him he
was the same he was very kind perhaps
i'm being pathetic but he definitely
loved life
sounds ironic now
president vladimir zelinsky says about 1
300 servicemen have lost their lives so
far but key ukrainian cities remain
surrounded as russia seems to be
expanding its targets around the country
it might take longer because the
ukrainian army is actually putting up a
fight but it seems that the russian
strategy is to surround cities like
kharkiv in the northeast or maripo in
the south besiege them and bring them
down to their knees before continuing
the advance and people here are leaving
because they feel that dinipro could be
next
the nipro was targeted for two days
trades with rockets coming from the east
either from territory under separatist
control or russia itself
this was an early morning missile
intercepted over the city center that
was caught on mobile phone
our air defense system is weaker than at
the beginning of the war the russians
targeted it on the first day they tried
to destroy it
we managed to evacuate staff it's
working still but not everything is
smooth
now they fire aimlessly from a long
distance they don't come close because
we still have a defense system but they
have capacity to hit from hundreds of
kilometers away
we ask the whole of the world to close
the sky
while ukraine's western allies are
refusing to enforce a no-fly zone it's
the families who are left to live with
their loss
alexander had married valeria less than
three months ago
now she's a young widow holding tight
the colors her husband defended to his
last breath
hoping it won't be in vain
ukraine